i
[Music]
good
well the truth is that it hurts me to
come between you and the food
although I think another
colleague is also missing but well I wanted to tell you about
some of the cases that we are
seeing with those who have counted as machin
I lost the  Two of
the cases that some
misfortune has recounted may seem a bit
far from what an architecture would be, a
traditional architecture, however
we think that
value can be found very quickly and
as another colleague from Dawn has also commented
, it is active starting to  apply
some of these technologies in
business architecture and in the
company and opens three examples that I
hope will serve as illustrative but that
is only really with those of us who
are really starting to use
machine learning with some of our
clients
the first are the monkeys me  i understand that
you are all familiar here with the
puddles in charlotte its a new channel
in the clients they prefer to use
messaging they prefer to use
well because thing-type tools to
interact with our companies is
something that was detected in the market a
long time ago and here we have been
creating new channels that are in
some way also transforming
even everything that is
customer service begins with something small, it
begins with a solution that perhaps
only has questions and answers but
then gradually what we are doing
is that when that little robot that does not
know much about our business
does not know about our service, well, it does not know  answers,
a human passes it on, that human in the
contingent of our offices also
helps the model to learn and understand
how to improve, and each time the robot is
becoming more intelligent
, we are also integrating the robot with our with
our layer, let's say clients with
our box  of crm
capable of call center and that makes that
activity
that interaction that is having
our user with the rest of
our channels is also
registered in that layer in such a way that
we
gradually get that interaction and more and more
based on the fact that I am more based on voice
more based behind
machine learning models we are going  to
introducing in the rest of the channels and
with that we transform very
gradually they have also told a
colleague before not to talk to him about the
transformation the automation of
casto pérez well because this first step
is a simple step that takes a few
weeks to transform that  case that
expense you serve me and well an example of the
site that is public and that is why I can
share it the one that we are doing this
is avianca the Colombian airline in
this airline the first version of the
chat that we did in seven weeks
well it began to change the
how customers check-in
review interview on itineraries
look
at site at destination p  But
gradually we are already in the next
phases because of the first phase and with
that alone we got 25,000 users and 700
thousand messages, that is, the users,
especially between the ages of 25 and
35, began to use this
massively and well, now we are already in the
next phases  phases as I have mentioned,
integrating the call center and integrating
with models with machine
learning models that allow the robot to learn
how to do or what to interact in these
specific scenarios, which
is travel, this is a case, but well,
we are really working on
very  similar because also to do
for banking for insurance for retail
also
the stores resistance linked to
ecommerce we are also working on
the model it is very similar
a second case that I wanted to comment on and
also to mention some of my
colleagues but I am going to delve a
little more is  customization at the
end customers when they seek
customization usually esp  we will
do with static rules we are going to put
the static rules that put some
banners to the page based on x and y
ceta based on its segment
based on the propensity that we think
it has and that is in the end something
static but the propensity and the
market scenario the product we
want to sell the price at which
we want to sell it is totally dynamic
with google yes we are getting
personalization platforms that not
only use us paint here
drawing the client better and better and
making it less blurry and it will allow us to
characterize  to detail that
client but also that we
achieve it in a dynamic way, that is, we
characterize the client in a
dynamic way and we are capable of injecting
models also of profession of
products of profession to promotions of
personalization of prices in the part
of the border here I had a small
scheme  in the one you see at the
bottom we are reading information
from the  of navigation information
of marketing tools data
'we have federated with businesses with which
we do not compete but that can share
their data with us of course in
our our crm in our
social information with that we are
drawing the client is being
characterized and the models that
characterize the client that they are
also training on the front we have
models that work in real time
instants the tools with
which this type of thing is done and I am capable
already attached to the application attached to the
channel of injecting personalization in real time
that is to say  the product that
I recommend in the search the price
that I recommend this to this I think
I offer this client etcetera and that
would be the other this intermediate layer of
customization platform is the one that
we are building in many
clients throughout the retail world in general
be it banking be
it retail be pure let's say consumer
we are working on this  The layers and the
difference between mounting them on, let's say,
traditional platforms and mounting them
on Google platforms is the same.
The last case I wanted to comment on is
the feel service of the technicians. This does not
also apply to the world of
sales, but I wanted to focus on the
world.  of the technical technicians of
refinery plants, distribution plants,
also the good technicians, well,
experts or technicians who can
solve
repair issues, etc. In an
insurance company,
we usually solve this type of scenario
with mobile applications that are
connected to the systems of  scheduling
and planning systems to
rc is basically
what we are seeing with google is that
we are able to build a totally different technical experience by combining
different apis and different
tools
not only in the
collaboration part that you have seen is that
you have been in the  'Chinese' but also
integrate themes such as reality  d augmented and
integrate everything that is reached in the
documentation the technician has to
use with character recognition searches
and also using those
models you have seen before and also the
ability of the application itself to
advise the technician and learn from the
technician so that those tips that
The technician gives him, above all, how he has to
act, they give each other feedback,
so the models learn and
they even learn from humans
how they have to respond, so the
technician has a chat there in which the one
who asks him things and if not  and if he
doesn't know how to answer, well, he's also
capable of
feeding that knowledge base and that
model,
all this here, doing it, let's say
two years ago, without this type of tools
that we've seen, because it was very expensive and
directly what we thought, hey,
we'll give you a list of  tasks a list
of work orders to the technician and well,
that you already like life, not in this
way we can do to
totally different mobile applications and as I
have told you and I hope I have illustrated you well,
much richer than the ones
we were doing very little ago it
is good I hope it has illustrated you
there are some examples
of what you have said before and
thank you and let go  to my partner on
the dam
[Applause]
[Music]